COULD HAPPEN.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS ON THE
END OF DAY 45 AMERICA IN SHUT
DOWN.
WHEN BLUE STATE GOVERNORS
JUSTIFY THEIR STAY-AT-HOME
ORDERS EVEN WITH COVID DEATHS IN
THEIR STATES RELATIVELY LOW,
THEY INVARIABLY REGURGITATE THE
SAME JUSTIFICATION.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, NOT JUDGED BY POLITICS OR
BY PROTEST, BUT BY SCIENCE.
>> NOT TO BE A BROKEN RECORD BUT
WE ARE LOOKING AT DATA.
>> WE HAVE TO MAKE THE BEST
INFORMED THE DECISIONS BASED ON
DATA AND SCIENCE.
>> IT SOUNDS GOOD BUT ARE THEY
ACTUALLY LISTENING TO THE
SCIENCE AND IS THE SCIENCE EVEN
SETTLED?
LAST MONTH BEFORE GOVERNORS
BEGAN LOCKING DOWN THEIR STATES,
PROMINENT STANFORD
EPIDEMIOLOGIST MADE A PRESCIENT
OBSERVATION.
HE SAID IN THE ABSENCE OF DATA,
PREPARE FOR THE WORST REASONING
LEADS TO EXTREME MEASURES AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING LOCKDOWNS.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THESE MEASURES
WORK.
RAISING THIS INCONVENIENT TRUTH
OR QUESTIONING THE ORTHODOXY,
THE GOOD PROFESSOR BECAME AN
INSTANT PARIAH IN THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT CIRCLES.
OTHERS JUST IGNORED HIM HOPING
HE WOULD GO AWAY, BUT NEW DATA
SEEMS TO SUPPORT SKEPTICISM OF
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
WHEN DO YOU KNOW THAT OUR DEAR
FRIENDS OVER AT FACEBOOK
ACTUALLY CREATED THEIR OWN
DATABASE THAT MEASURES AND
TRACKS SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
EVERY U.S. STATE?
THEY USED TWO DIFFERENT METRICS,
THE FIRST IS CALLED RELATIVE
MOBILITY CHANGED WHICH IS HOW
OFTEN SOMEONE TRAVELS OUTSIDE
HIS OR HER AREA.
THE SECOND IS A STAPLE AT
PERCENTAGE, OR PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO STAYED IN THEIR HOME
FOR THE DAY.
IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY ENOUGH, WE
SEE THAT THE STATES WITH THE
LARGEST DROPS IN RELATIVE
MOBILITY AND THE LARGEST
INCREASES IN THE STATE PUT
PERCENTAGE ARE ALSO THE STATES
WITH THE MOST CONFIRMED COVID
CASES AND DEATHS.
NEW YORKERS AND NEW JERSEY WERE
UNDERSTANDABLY TERRIFIED THIS
VIRUS AND TOOK THE STAY-AT-HOME
ORDERS QUITE SERIOUSLY BUT THE
VIRUS CONTINUED TO SPREAD TO.
WOULD IT HAVE BEEN WORSE WITHOUT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING?
MAY BE.
DO WE KNOW THAT FOR CERTAIN?
NO.
ALTHOUGH THE FACEBOOK MAPPING
ISN’T DISPOSITIVE, IT MERELY
CONFIRMS OR RECONFIRMS WHAT WE
NEED TO ASK AND THE QUESTIONS WE
NEED ANSWERED ABOUT THE TRUE
EFFICACY OF THESE SOCIAL
MITIGATION MEASURES.
REMEMBER, EXPERTS DON’T LIKE TO
ADMIT THEY’RE WRONG, DO THEY?
THEY’RE SUPPOSED TO BE SMARTER
THAN THE REST OF US ON ALL THIS
STUFF.
THEN THERE’S THE OTHER NEW
ARTICLE OF COVID, MASKS.
LIKE MOST AMERICANS WEEKS AGO I
BEGAN WEARING A MASK WHILE
GROCERY SHOPPING.
I HAVE BEEN A NOTORIOUS GERMAN
PHOBIC FOR DECADES, IT’S SO BAD
THAT MY FELLOW AIRLINE
PASSENGERS USED TO LOOK AT ME
REALLY WEIRDLY WHEN I CARRIED
OUT MY RITUAL DISINFECTING
REGIMEN THAT I DO.
IT SPRAYS AND WIPING DOWN, NOW
EVERYBODY’S A GERMAN FOE.
WHAT’S THE BIG DEAL.
THEN I STARTED TO SEE PEOPLE
FIDDLING WITH MASS, TOUCHING
THEIR FACES, READJUSTING THEIR
MASKS, EVEN SHAMING OTHERS FOR
NOT WEARING MASKS, RUNNING PAST
SOMEONE 10 FEET AWAY, YOU’RE NOT
WEARING A MASK.
I STARTED ASK QUESTIONS.
DO THESE MASKS REALLY SLOW THE
SPREAD OF COVID?
IT SEEMED LIKE 5 MINUTES AGO WE
WERE TOLD THEY WANT NECESSARY AT
ALL AND NOW THEIR EYES AS
COMMONPLACE AS SWEATPANTS.
NUMEROUS AIRLINES ARE AS OF
TODAY REQUIRING THEM OF BOTH
CREW AND PASSENGERS.
MASKS ARE BECOMING FASHION
ACCESSORIES.
BUT SINCE WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
GUIDED BY ACTUAL FACTS, WHAT
DOES THE SCIENCE ACTUALLY SAY
ABOUT MASKS?
I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE N95
MASK.
THE COLORADO SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SAYS THE HOMEMADE COTTON
MASK ONLY STOP ABOUT 2% OF THE
AIR FLOW COMING IN 2%.
THEY ARE GOOD IN THE MEDICAL
SETTING, OPERATING ROOM, MEDICAL
PROCEDURES, THEY AREN’T VERY
EFFECTIVE OUT IN PUBLIC.
SHE SAID THESE MASKS DON’T SEAL
AGAINST 70% OF THE OUTSIDE AIR
AND 30% TRAVELS AROUND THE SIDE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MASKS DON’T
CATCH THE DROPLETS.
IF EXPERTS ADVISING THE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS WANT THE
REST OF US TO TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY, THEN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE TO BE
REASONABLE AND WELL-FOUNDED.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF THEY WERE
OCCASIONALLY CONSISTENT.
IF THEY ARE NOT, NO ONE’S GOING
TO LISTEN AND IF THEY AREN’T
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR BEING
WRONG, I DON’T KNOW WHERE THAT
LEADS US.
I’M TELLING YOU, BE PREPARED TO
AS ALL OF THIS PLAYS OUT FOR
MORE PETTY POWER GRABS AND I’M
TALKING ABOUT THE SORT WE’VE
SEEN FROM MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER.
TODAY, ANTI-SHUT DOWN PROTESTERS
CONVERGED ON THE STATE CAPITAL,
PRESUMABLY STATE REPS LISTENED
AND THEY ADJOURNED WITHOUT
EXTENDING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
EMERGENCY.
WE’LL SEE WHAT GOVERNOR WHITMER
DOES NOW, APPARENTLY SHE IS
YAWNING.
AMERICANS ARE SMART AND NOW THEY